For this equation, the final solution was negative 5 and negative 14 5ths. Both
of these values work for b. Great work if you found these two answers. I know
one of them was a fraction, and you might not have gotten all the way there.
But I hope you were able to make the substitution for b plus 3 and at least
find the values for u. Let's see how we do that. We can start by making the
substitution u equals b plus 3. So wherever I see b plus 3, replace that with a
u. Now we want to solve this quadratic equation, so we need to move this term
to the left hand side. So, we'll have a quadratic expression here and 0 on the
right. After subtracting 2 from both sides, we want to try and factor this
expression. We find factors of negative 10 that sum to positive 9. Those
factors are negative 1 and positive 10. We use factoring by grouping to get
these two factors equal to 0. Then, we can set each of these factors equal to 0
to solve for the values of u. U can equal negative 2, or u can equal 1 5th. So,
since we know u equals negative 2 and u equals 1 5th, we can say b plus 3
equals negative 2 and b plus 3 equals 1 5th. We solve for this value of b to
get b equals negative 5. Over here, we'll subtract 3 from both sides to get b
equals 1 5th minus 3. We'll change 3 into 15 5ths and then subtract to get
negative 14 5ths.